Andrew why now Eric I think this is
really an interesting time and it's it's
hard to figure out why now but he has
stuck his stake in the ground Adam
silver has and really broken off from
his brethren commissioners here in
putting forward a proposal for gambling
I think the why now relates to being
proactive getting ahead of the other
commissioners and wanting to say it's
better in the light than in the shadows
he caucus
talks about regulations we should make
it federal and we have a hearing coming
up in New Jersey opposing betting
opposing sports betting what he's saying
is he's a clever lawyer he's saying on
the one hand we still oppose that but if
we had a federal comprehensive program
we wouldn't be dealing with these
individual state problems that we have I
think he's getting ahead of it and I
think we can't ignore the monetization
angle here as well they just did a deal
with FanDuel a fantasy sports company so
that's part of this as well so that's
his incentive
I think the all these commissioners are
trying to figure out what's the
monetization angle here how do we
control it how do we monetize this
rather than somebody else doing it and
yes the first deal out there is FanDuel
and the NBA last week and all of a
sudden we go wait a minute Wow the NBA
is taking control of the fantasy sports
angle here where other commissioners are
sitting back and saying how do we
monetize this silvers stepping out and
doing it first so this is just like
Colorado legalizing marijuana
everybody's doing it why don't we take
charge of the process so we can track it
and tax it and everybody wins absolutely
I think this is very comparable to what
went on with legalized marijuana he's
saying it's better out in the light than
in the shadows and he talks about strict
federal regulations oh and with the new
jersey thing he's almost saying hey
federal government we're gonna keep
opposing these state laws until you do
something federal it's really a
challenge to Congress saying let's
legalize this it's just interesting of
all the things a new Commissioner wants
to stake his claim on now the reactor
that this Donald sterling thing was a
reaction to those comments but he has
picked gambling which really flies in
the face of integrity
in some ways so is the NBA going to be
the new legal bookie I think that's what
they want they want a country they want
the government to be the legal bookie
they want the government to control this
area just like we talked about with
marijuana they want the government to
regulate this so they don't have the
dark side coming to players coming to
referees potentially compromising the
integrity of the sport I think that's
what's going on here
when you say Andrew that this flies in
the face of integrity what do you mean
by that well in normal situations
gambling's flies in the face of
integrity we go way back with Pete Rose
with the Black Sox scandal and in 1920
with Tim Donaghy a referee in the NBA
who was accused of throwing games and
fixing games so wait when you talk about
integrity Wow
gambling that strikes at the heart of
integrity except for the fact that
gambling happens as silver points out in
his op-ed and it's going to happen
whether Congress legalizes it or not and
if players are gonna throw games to make
money with bookies they're going to do
it aren't they whether it's legal or not
well Silver's saying let's flip the page
let's flip it let's make it legal
therefore it won't they won't be
susceptible to this you you reference
the key line I thought in your opening
there is an obvious appetite for safe
and legal wagering in this country he is
looking at that and saying let's make it
obvious and safe and let's make it legal
all right then Andrew what is your
opinion of his move okay I think this is
coming I think this is inevitable I
think there is no way that gambling
stays under the surface besides Nevada
it's just too much of an appetite the
NFL has fantasy sports on nfl.com that's
gambling the NHL has fantasy sports
Major League Baseball has fantasy sports
now we can say it just fantasy it's with
your kids but that's the tip of the
iceberg this is coming so the leaks have
to get ahead of it so I commend Adam
silver for getting in front of it the
question is how how are we going to
handle this huge appetite for gambling
in a safe and legal manner that's up to
Congress that's up to people beyond the
NBA but they're stepping out in front of
it what are the what clearly there are
some obvious risks what about the risks
we haven't thought of Andrew well the
obvious risk is really players being
paid off I think that is you know that
sounds dramatic I just don't see it
happening and especially in team sports
to say that one player in football or
basketball or baseball can control the
outcome of a game these are team sports
and the fact is Eric they make so much
money for them to risk that for whatever
it's gonna be now again if they're
offered tens of millions of dollars
that's a different story
I just don't see that happening I think
the risk is integrity the risk is that
we as a public say maybe that sport is
not as clean as we thought
but again silver believes the other way
is better having it legal is better than
what we have now which is illegal and it
sounds like you agree with them I think
it's coming I think I guess I commend
him for getting out of it I'm not sure I
agree with gambling and sports in it
together but eventually it's coming
whether we like